KRISTAN UCCELLO: Well, yet
again, another Google TV
Office Hours Hangout.
And I'm Kristan Uccello,
and this is Christian.
And we're joined right now by
Leon, who's going to give us a
demo in a short bit.
It's been a little while since
we've done a Hangout.
There's a good reason for that,
mostly to do with all of
us traveling at the same time.
So two weeks ago, I was
traveling, you were traveling,
Les was traveling, Paul
was traveling,
and Osama was traveling.
So there was literally
no one to really be
around to do the Hangout.
Not that we need to do it here,
but I think the problem
was, we were just scattered
and busy.
So hopefully that won't
happen again.
We're going to do one more
Hangout in two weeks time
before we stop them for the
year, and wait till 2013 rolls
around, and start
them up again.
So--
CHRISTIAN: That is, if the world
doesn't end in December.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: That's true.
The Mayan calendar does
predict our doom and
destruction on, I think,
December 22.
CHRISTIAN: Something
like that.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So we're
guaranteed to have at least
one more of Google TV Office
Hours Hangout before the end
of the world--
these being the end
times and all.
So with that, we've actually
got a lot of--
CHRISTIAN: I think we got
v3 right before the
world ended, so--
KRISTAN UCCELLO: We did.
Actually, that's the first
news item I was
going to bring up.
So version 3 of Google TV, the
platform, has launched on the
LG devices that are out there.
So this is a pretty big and
significant milestone.
Those of you with Sonys, and
Visios, and Logitech--
I don't know if the Logitechs--
are they being updated?
CHRISTIAN: Well, we pushed, I
think, some new YouTube app,
and the new TV Movies app, but
not the full capabilities of
the app on the v3.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Right,
OK so there's--
pardon me--
there is a partial that's
going out to the earlier
generation devices, the [? RM ?]
generation devices,
it'll be rolling out in the
next little while overall.
But it's kind of big
and exciting.
We've got a lot of
UI improvements.
We've got all the things that
we kind of talked about at
I/O. To recap, I think some
of the big ones are--
CHRISTIAN: I think, for users,
if you just use it in your
living room, it has to become
a little bit more, I want to
say, user friendly.
The TV and movies application
is a little
bit easier to browse.
We keep talking, always,
about things how to
optimize for D-pad.
And so we tried to experiment
around with the UI layout.
So if you notice right now,
the shelves actually, are
scrolling left and right.
Before, when you go out to
the right, you would
open up a new window.
The other thing that I
personally like a lot is the
little mini guide that comes up
when you just watch TV, and
you press the guide button.
You get an instant overlay with
all the channel guides,
and movies, and everything.
And from a developer's point of
view, so I've just, again,
on Google+, replied to somebody
who was, let's just
say, discontent with the
performance of transitions and
animations on Google TV.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Well, you know,
it's not unreasonable to
expect infinite gigateraflop
performance on a
device that's sub-$100.
But go on.
CHRISTIAN: So if you take a look
at the mini guide on TV,
you'll notice, it scrolls
really smooth.
And we have really nice
transitions in there.
It's not using native code.
So I just want to stress that.
It's actually all implemented in
Android using the same APIs
that are available for third
party developers.
The only a small trick, I want
to call it, is, we're using,
actually, OpenGL.
So what this shows is there is
some performance behind the
graphics chip, you just
have to get into it.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You've got to
understand how to tap into it.
It's not going to be the
boilerplate, cut and paste
code that makes your
app wonderful.
You've got to dig in.
You've got to geek out a little
bit on this hardware.
CHRISTIAN: I think it's a great
opportunity for people
to actually differentiate
and do some really
cool transition effects.
Honestly, you're not going to
do that for every screen in
your app, but having one or two
real focus point screens--
like, in the YouTube
application, we have the
little media carousel in the
bottom where you can scroll
through YouTube videos.
That's also done in OpenGL.
It's really worth it.
If you want to spend a little
bit of time just playing
around with OpenGL, you can
do some amazing stuff.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Now, do you
know if it's OpenGL 1.0, 1.1,
2.0, because there's
a big difference
between 1.1 and 2.0.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, so I think
it's OpenGL ES, I
believe, it's 2.0.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: It's 2.0.
So it's all the vector shaders
and fragment shaders, which
is, that's a whole world
onto itself.
That requires really digging in
to the graphic stacks and
understanding things.
You're not going to get
boilerplate performance.
CHRISTIAN: It's exciting.
I mean, I have not played
with shaders.
That's on my to-do list for sure
the Christmas holidays.
While other people eat good
foods and visit families, I'll
be playing with shaders.
But I've played around
a little bit
with just basic OpenGL.
And just simple stuff, like
drawing a bunch of triangles
on the screen.
It's actually pretty cool.
So I'm going to, actually,
talk about this
next week at AnDevCon.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah, Christian
and I are both going
to be there.
Believe me, we're cooking up
something really interesting.
If you are lucky enough to
have an AnDevCon ticket,
you're really going to want to
come and see what we're going
to be doing on stage.
It's our hope that this will be
talked about it, let's say,
in wide circles.
CHRISTIAN: There will be
Google+ posts about it.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: There'll
be hardware porn, too.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, well
that's Chris' piece.
He wants to take
[? them coming and going ?].
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So I think
you've actually
already hit on this one.
So, YouTube Google TV pairing,
this is the next--
CHRISTIAN: That's cool, yeah.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah,
so, there was an
update that went out.
Is it all devices?
I can't remember.
Or is it coming, or--?
CHRISTIAN: It's all a blur.
It's definitely on the LG
devices, I have it at home.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So you can
essentially use your phone or
your tablet to hunt for videos
and throw them to your screen
or your TV, and it just plays.
I guess it would be
fun at parties--
and, hey, look at
this cat video.
Or look at this Google TV
Office Hours video.
[LAUGHTER]
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Completely
unrelated, but still
newsworthy--
Hisense Google TVs are
now showing up,
actually, in Amazon.
So yet another device that
we've already alluded to,
talked about before, Hisense
is joining us.
Hey, Les.
LES: Aloha.
CHRISTIAN: Aloha.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Just in the
middle of the news, but we can
pause here.
How's Hawaii?
LES: It's nice, actually.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Nice?
It's raining here today
in Mountain View.
LES: We get rain here.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: All
right, so yes.
Hisense is available.
Well, I should say, it's
showing up in Amazon.
It says temporarily out of
stock, so I don't know whether
there was actually a batch that
they sold out, or if it's
just sort of like you get your
pre-orders in or get notified--
but I know Amazon has it, so
it must be coming soon.
Voice search.
This is one of the new things
that got rolled out.
You can now control your LG TV
with voice control off your
remote, which is pretty awesome,
especially for those
who have thick fat fingers,
like me, who have trouble
typing on small keyboards.
This is a boon for finding all
those episodes of "Glee" I
want to watch.
CHRISTIAN: It works, actually,
surprisingly well.
I was a little bit skeptical
at first.
I don't like to talk to my TV.
But once I used it a few
times, I prefer it over
typing, even on the back
of this little
keyboard thing here.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So it'll
be exciting to see
how this gets used.
There were some questions, I
believe, about our remote
control app getting updated
to include a voice feature
because people want this on the
Google TVs that have yet
to be updated.
LES: Leon has it in his.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah,
so I was actually
going to use this--
LES: You were going to
segue there, cool.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: The segue But
thanks for [INAUDIBLE], Les.
Yeah, so Leon, since we have you
on the line, I'm going to
ask you this directly.
Do you have voice search already
in your remote control
implementation for Android?
LEON: Yeah, I do.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: And so where
can people go and get that?
It's open source, right?
You've open sourced your code?
LEON: [INAUDIBLE]
So they can get that
in the Play Store.
But we've had the voice feature
for quite a while, and
it's one of the most popular
features, actually.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Cool, so I
suspect that answers the
question to the people who were,
I believe, asking it on
the Google TV plus page.
There's a Hangout tomorrow at
around 3:30 to talk about
voice control and
voice features.
So if you're interested in the
user end side of that, you
want to check out the Hangout
that's going on tomorrow.
Last two quick pieces of news--
actually, we've already
talked about AnDevCon.
So--
CHRISTIAN: Let's talk a
little more about it.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: We should.
CHRISTIAN: It's local
in the Bay Area.
It's up in Burlingham, right
by the airport Hyatt.
I think, today, you still
can get tickets.
Let us know if you really
want to come.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: If you're going
to buy tickets, yeah
speaker codes.
So--
you don't care.
OK, so if you use my last name,
U-C-C-E-L-L-O, you might
still be able to utilize the
coupon code, and it should get
you $200 off the ticket.
So yeah.
That's there.
And you and I are talking for
two sessions straight.
Yeah, Wednesday afternoon
is all about Google TV.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yes.
From, what was it?
CHRISTIAN: I think 1:30
to 5:00 or something.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Something
like that.
Yeah, we've got a significant
amount of time.
And we've got a good
show planned.
CHRISTIAN: We'll be cooking
something up.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN: It's all about
the holiday season.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: It is.
We should just rename it
the Home Cooking Show.
Maybe I've said too much.
[LAUGH]
All right, lastly--
what's that Les?
LES: If I may.
Christian and I were
there last year.
And it is really got some of
the best, most focused
developers that I've
seen in a while.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: We're
going to eat this up.
LES: It's very technical.
Lots of folks who are
really smart there.
CHRISTIAN: I mean, I'm
always impressed.
Mostly everyone I talk with at
the conference is either a
Android expert and author or is
a, I want to say, respected
Stack Overflow personality.
So it it's really very
technical, very deep dive
Android expertise.
So if you are an Android
developer, and you are
somewhere local, I like it.
I mean it's, to me, this is
really a great event.
It's one of the highlights
of the year.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Cool.
It comes almost directly
opposite I/O.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah well,
they also--
I don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing, but they
have two AnDevCon conferences
per year.
So there's a spring
and a fall.
As I said, I think it's a
great gathering to bring
people together.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Cool.
All right, last item
on the news.
Just sort of to bring us full
circle, I alluded there was
some traveling going on.
I was in Mexico, doing
Esto Es Google,
which is This Is Google.
Very, very big audience
showed up.
I think there was almost 3,000
developers that showed up to
this free event in Mexico.
And we showcased and highlighted
Google TV, got a
prominent spot.
I ended up giving two
one-hour lectures
there to packed rooms.
I think the capacity of the
rooms was like 380 people.
Very receptive, very warm,
welcoming people.
I actually got into a drinking
game on Google TV trivia
afterwards.
But that's for another time.
And Les, that you were in
Colorado, I think, at this
time, too, weren't you?
LES: Yeah.
Paul Karth and I were
in Colorado.
We did Boulder Droids.
And we also held a day-long
session there.
And we had about 40-someodd
people for Boulder Droids and
20-someodd for the day longs.
And it was a really
good session.
I think we'll get a
lot of developers
developing apps from that.
It was a very exciting thing.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You sound
a little worn out.
Are you still recovering
from all the activity?
LES: No I, just actually,
I read in the morning.
And so I just happened
to be vertical.
And I signed on and it
said, oh, you've been
invited to a Hangout.
And I'm like, oh, I didn't
realize that.
But OK, I'll join in.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: All
right, cool, cool.
All right, so actually,
there weren't many
questions that I saw today.
I guess everyone's kind of
busy working on their
television apps for Christmas,
trying to
get it in the market.
CHRISTIAN: It's the season.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: It's
the season.
Actually there was an app
that came up recently
that got some buzz.
Maybe we'll talk about
that later.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, yeah.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So I guess,
without further ado, let's go
to this really cool demo that
Leon has put together.
I saw this, and I was like,
that's --expletive--
awesome.
So Leon, I'm going to
hand it over to you.
Why don't you just sort of
explain what you did, why you
did it, and how it works.
And let's see it in action.
LEON: OK, so I've created a
program that allows you to use
your Microsoft Kinect sensor
to control your Google TV.
And you use gestures it instead
of a physical remote.
So I think the best way
to show it off is
just to play the video.
So we can give this a try.
LEON (IN VIDEO): I've written
a program that allows you to
use your Microsoft
Kinect Sensor to
control your Google TV.
[INAUDIBLE]
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So do you want
to describe what's going
on while this is happening?
LEON (IN VIDEO): [INAUDIBLE]
LEON: Yeah, basically, it's just
Google TV showing off.
In the corner there is just
the app from the device.
LEON (IN VIDEO): [INAUDIBLE]
KRISTAN UCCELLO: And so I see
your gestures are moving the
pointer on the screen.
LEON: Yeah.
LEON (IN VIDEO): [INAUDIBLE]
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Now, did you
write that screen software, or
is that a package
or something?
LEON: So it's a combination of
some of some open source
drivers and some software.
But the gesture stuff and
talking to Google TV is all
done in my program.
LEON (IN VIDEO): [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTIAN: And so, how do you
communicate with Google TV in
this example?
So you effectively send any mode
cursor position to the
Google TV, or how do you control
the cursor there?
LEON: Yeah, so I've written a
library for any mode in Java
that I'm using there.
And so yeah, I am continuing to
be, basically, the mouse.
[INAUDIBLE]
Google TV as though I'm moving
my finger on a touch control
on a physical remote.
LEON (IN VIDEO): [INAUDIBLE]
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So how do you
find the usability, I guess,
of gesture control.
LEON: Yeah, so that
gets interesting.
Let me get out of the video.
So that's quite interesting
because the easy part is doing
the gestures with your hand,
which seem to be a point.
But now, when you start
navigating Google TV, there's
more things you need
to do, like, for
example, selecting things.
So I made a gesture where you
kind of hold up your hand and
push it forward.
It's like clicking
on something.
It gets more complicated,
though.
Now that you're, let's say, in
an app, and maybe there's a
list of things you need to
scroll through, well, now you
need another gesture for that,
too, because just moving your
hand is just going to
move the pointer.
It's not actually scrolling.
So now you need to keep on
coming up with gestures that
will map to things that
you would do on
the physical remote.
Like, even the D-pad stuff, how
would you do left, right,
up, and down.
And you think about this is a
very different way, because,
again, moving your hand is just
going to move a pointer.
It's not going to get
[INAUDIBLE] up and down like
on the physical keys.
So I put some hooks
in the code.
And the program is really just
kind of a thing for somebody
to play with because there are
many ways, many directions you
could go to solve
that problem.
One gesture I put in the
code is to go back.
And the solution I came
up with that was to
hold up both hands.
And then you go like that.
And that's a gesture
for going back.
But you can imagine coming
up with your own
ways of doing that.
It's just, now, you don't want
to confuse moving this hand
with moving the pointer.
So you can see, I'm already
getting awkward,
[? here ?], aren't I?
Just being able to do
the gesture stuff.
To really pull this off, I
think you really need to
rethink the Google TV UI to be
much more gesture-based.
There's simple things like,
things need to be bigger to be
able to target it.
So, like a button.
If it's a small button, for me
to kind of move my hand and
just getting the aim right
is kind of tricky.
Especially clicking on things.
Now, if the button was much
bigger, which is what LG did
with their UI because they
support a gesture-based UI, so
their buttons on their main
launcher screen are huge.
So it makes it very easy to
point and click at things.
But as you get into other
types of navigation like
scrolling and other things, you
need to think about how
you would do that in the
gesture-based UI because it's
not just simply mapping the
current way to gestures.
It can get complicated.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So, is your
next project going to be
writing a new home screen
application to make gesture
control a lot easier?
LEON: Yes, but it's
not for gestures.
It's something else
I'm working.
But yeah, I mean, I open
sourced the code.
So anybody can go and play.
The code should work
on any platform.
The real issue at the moment
is that you still need a
computer because the gesture
recognition and communication
is actually kind
of heavyweight.
This sensor doesn't actually
do gesture recognition.
It just gives you raw data.
So you need a beefy
CPU to do that.
Originally, I wanted to do
this all of my little
Raspberry Pie, but I that
little thing just
can't handle it.
You're basically looking at
raw video at 30 frames a
second, and you need to figure
out the gestures within that.
That's a lot of heavy
CPU load.
So you need a laptop, and then
you need the Kinect sensor,
obviously, and then the code.
You can just download it.
Even if you don't understand
the code, it's easy to
download, and set it up,
and just run it.
And then hopefully, some
developers will start digging
into the code and start seeing,
well, what gestures
make sense for the TV?
It's something to play with.
It's not quite practical
at this stage.
There are some orientation
issues and navigation issues,
in terms of making sure
the point is always
in the right place.
But again, that's something that
developers can play with
and see what makes sense.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah, I think
a lot of this is still--
this is uncharted territory,
in a lot of ways.
I know how the Kinect with
Microsoft's play in the living
room to get in gesture mode.
Nintendo had their Wiimotes
and the cameras built into
their little Bluetooth
devices.
And Sony has their glowing
wands, which are pretty cool.
But, I mean, all of them have
different strengths and
weaknesses, as do all
gesture-based controls.
I'm hoping that the future, with
whatever new technologies
are coming out, maybe we'll see
some blended integration
all these things,
and LIDAR, and--
I want to live in the
future again.
LEON: I thnk one promising
combination might be gestures
with voice.
That could be an interesting
combination.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You mean,
like grunts and growls?
LEON: That you could point at
easily, rather than saying,
right-- you can say that,
and point at it.
So I think that might be a
natural way of doing it,
rather than something else,
some other combination of
technologies.
CHRISTIAN: I personally wonder
if it's actually physically
possible that we could do eye
tracking or something.
Because with screens getting
bigger, I can definitely look
at sections of the screen.
I could find like six or so
sections of the screen that I
can focus on with my eyes.
And I don't need any control
device at that point.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Well, as humans
we tend to use our eyes
and see where other people are
looking anyway-- and gesture,
and give verbal sort of, action,
to those gestures.
So I think, yeah, maybe there is
some combination here that
could work.
LEON: So we have started
this project.
That's exactly what
I want to do.
Figuring out where your
eyes are looking at.
That is very complicated.
So there are solutions for
things that are close, like
your screen.
But when you get to some
distance, like sitting in
front of a TV, actually, there
isn't any commercial solution
at the moment because it's so
difficult, then, to pick up
your eyes and to do
that accurately.
So originally, yeah, I was
looking for an eye sensor.
And I thought I maybe could
hack that with Kinect, but
it's not quite there.
The resolution you get
is not good enough to
pick up your eyes.
So there's a company that's
working on a solution.
But even though they claim they
have something for TVs,
you still need to sit quite
close to the TV.
But yes, that was what
I was trying to do.
I didn't want to do
the gestures.
So the Kinect thing was kind
of a fall back because the
technology isn't there yet.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: We'll see what
the future brings with
glass and all that
other stuff.
Yeah.
LES: I would think, for an eye
tracker, for a TV at 3.3
meters, the movement of the eye
is so subtle that it'd be
very difficult to pick up.
Even with a tracker mounted
on your glasses.
CHRISTIAN: It's just amazing
to me, always--
I mean, when we try to do stuff
like this, and we look
at how easy it is for actual
human beings to do that--
when I speak with somebody
from like five feet, or,
whatever, two meters away, I can
tell if they look at me or
the person standing next
to me, maybe less
than a meter away.
But yeah, for a camera, or for
a TV device, this is really
still almost undoable.
LES: Right, but it's difficult
to tell if somebody's looking
at your nose, or your
mouth, or your ears.
That's a bit more challenging.
Yeah.
We're probably many
decades out from a
full solution to that.
But who knows, maybe in the
future, everyone will be
walking around with
helmets on.
That could make things
a whole lot easier.
Just a target right
over the head.
Or like, how the Sims
have it, glowing
diamonds, it's your companion.
I don't know.
I'm going into the deep
sci-fi realm there.
LES: Do we have any
questions today?
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Nobody asked
anything in the [? Dori ?].
But James Power did ask one in
the Plus page, which I'm going
to bring up here because we
talked about it a little bit
at the beginning.
James asked, I'd like to hear
a bit more about the OpenGL
widget system Primetime
is using.
Is any of that open source?
Could it be?
My current animation woes
are specific to fragment
transitions.
I'm not sure how to implement
things in OpenGL.
Well, that actually might speak
to the first part of it.
Let's see.
It seems like it would require
quite a large rewrite.
Maybe I'm mistaken.
Also the feedback is pretty
terrible at the moment.
It sounds like it's coming
from Mountain View.
It probably is.
I apologize for that.
The space that we're in now has
been torn down, I think,
six times in the last three days
to do various activities.
We've had a photo shoot here.
We've had usability testing.
We've had another Hangout
earlier, there was a meeting.
Things got moved around.
Things will be getting better.
There's a new studio
in the works.
I've nothing official to
announce, but the quality of
these Hangouts will be improving
as we go forward.
So keep tuning in.
Provide us with feedback.
That would be great.
So let's go back to James
question here and see what we
can do to answer that.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Well,
Les could maybe talk
to that from Hawaii.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LES: [? Kristy ?] was going to
answer that instead of me.
I tried.
I'm still trying to open source
an OpenGL library.
We were trying for
one idea and got
blocked on internal stuff.
So yeah, we feel your pain.
We understand it.
We'd really like to fix it.
Any we've got support of
Google TV engineering.
It's just--
I'll check in with the team that
blocked us and see if we
could do something else.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: I have
something to add here.
So OpenGL is definitely
something I'm extremely
interested in.
And I have a long background
of graphics programming.
I mean, this is why I got into
programming was games, and
we're talking like old
school Sinclair Z81.
This is the kind of stuff
I was doing--
CHRISTIAN: They had
a OpenGL Z81?
KRISTAN UCCELLO: No, no.
If we had OpenGL back then,
I would be doing something
completely different by now.
But the point is, I'm
digging into this.
And one of the things that
I think is probably worth
mentioning, especially if you're
new to OpenGL, is that
there are two distinct
flavors.
There's the ES 1.0
flavor, and 1.1.
Those are very similar.
And then you've got OpenGL 2.
I'm just going to
call it ES 1.
That encompasses both versions
of 1 and 1.1.
In ES 1, there's a lot of
convenience methods that sort
of do of the some heavy lifting
for you in setting up
your graphics pipeline and
program compilation.
There is a lot of convenience
in what goes on there.
And you can, oftentimes, you can
write very functional code
in your application to
make your frames
render the way you want.
If you start looking at the way
OpenGL ES 2 works, it's
actually more complicated
to set up.
And there are less convenience
functions.
Everything's been sort of pushed
into vector shaders and
fragment shaders, which, if
you have no idea what I'm
talking about with regards to
shaders, that means you need
to do some reading and
some experimenting.
And it's worth the investment
because these things translate
into regular OpenGL.
But the point I'm trying to
make is, you need to use a
library framework on top of
OpenGL ES 2 to use it
effectively.
You're not going to write some
huge game just in shaders.
So there are books that there.
There are several good ones.
Some of the critiques of these
books has been, oh, the
author's just pushing their
library or their framework
with their book.
These are good things.
These help you get
things done.
Either write your own-- and
what programs [INAUDIBLE]
falling into writing
frameworks.
Or just pick one that's out
there that's being used and
kind of invest in it.
I mean, it's still early days
for a lot of this stuff.
And we could go a long
distance with it.
LES: I'll just throw
one more point.
Leon did some experimentation
with OpenGL recently.
Do you want to talk about
any of that stuff?
LEON: Sure, yeah.
So I did a little experiment, in
fact, I released as an app,
or overlay, which is
is the Play Store.
What I wanted to do was just
simple graphics where I
animate sprites--
little images that move
across the street.
And I did some testing
on that.
And this might be unique for the
kind of style of app that
I did, but I actually found
that the Android canvas
animation was better
than OpenGL.
So again, just, it's not
a general thing.
It's a very particular
type of animation.
But just moving images across
the screen and animating them
was significantly faster,
at least on
the Google TV devices.
When I did the same test on my
Nexus phone or tablet, they
were very similar.
Or the OpenGL worked a
little bit better.
So there's something, at least
with that kind of animation,
that you might just want to
consider this using standard
Android canvas.
The performance is very good.
I could get up to about 60
frames a second, which is very
good for the Google
TV platform.
CHRISTIAN: So Leon, which
hardware did you use when you
tried that out?
Was that on the Intel-phased
review or was it the new
arm-based devices?
So I've tried it on
all my devices.
I've tried it on the Logitech,
on Visio, on the Sony--
they're all very similar
numbers.
The Sony was a little bit better
on the OpenGL, but
still OpenGL was about half
the speed of the Android
canvas that I mentioned.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So I've got
some followup questions.
I haven't looked at your code
yet, but I guess what I want
to know is, what kind
of movement was it?
Was this 2D?
What kind of polygons
were you using?
What sort of parameters did you
put the GL state machine
in when you were doing
this animation?
LEON: So the code I
used for testing
was released by Google.
So you can go try it yourself.
It's called Sprite
Method Test.
There's a bunch of these
Android apps
that were open source.
And it's one of the
standard ones.
So it's not my code.
It's Google's code.
And so you can take
a look at that.
And so part of that code, when
you run it, it actually gives
you some data.
It gives you the frame rate.
It gives you various other
parameters in terms of how
quick the writes get done
to the screen and so on.
For me, it was more important
about the frame rate because I
want to be as soon
as possible.
So yeah, if you want to dig into
it, it's your own code.
[LAUGH]
KRISTAN UCCELLO: I was going
to say-- awkward.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTIAN: Like, somebody else
in the company that you don't
know must've written that.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: There's
somebody in the company you
don't know?
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, there's
one or two people.
Must be new ones.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: There's
a lot of us here.
But ironic, that we'd find
out about it this way.
But such is life.
LEON: So also open sourced my
code, so if you want to look
at it, you can do that too.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: OK, no,
that would be cool.
I think that might
be, actually, a
good discussion point.
Since we have Daniel on the
line, Daniel, did you have any
questions for us?
Daniel's video feed
[INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL: [INAUDIBLE]
find it difficult to activate my
Google Hangout on my tablet
is kind of mute.
So I'm trying to find a
way to address that.
Just a second.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: If you have a
question, maybe then, if you
can't hear or you don't feel
comfortable speaking it, you
could always type it out, and
we can answer it that way.
Otherwise--
LEON: I've got a questions
for you guys.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: OK.
LEON: So recently the YouTube
feature was released that
allows you to fling content to
Google TV, which is an awesome
feature, just really
excellent.
One problem, though, is that
when you select the device to
send it to, it actually gives
you the list of all your
Google TV devices
on your network.
But at the moment, it's labeling
them all Google TV,
so you don't know which
one it's going to.
And in fact, [INAUDIBLE]
it's not even in
the same order.
So you can't rely on position
to know where it's going.
So you kind of go through the
list in a hit and miss--
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You've
discovered
the Easter egg game.
LES: Crispy, could you write
that up as a bug.
CHRISTIAN: I think somebody,
actually, already mentioned
that they would like to give
a friendly name to
their Google TV.
LES: Oh right, we're
trying to fix that.
LEON: Yeah, that would be one
way because then the user can
actually put something in,
if that's possible.
But at the moment, it's just--
even though it's a great
feature, it's great for people
with one device.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Cool.
All right, if there's no more
questions, which I'm just
going to quickly check
the post list here.
LES: And see if Eduardo
has any questions.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Sorry?
LES: Eduardo just joined us.
Maybe he has a question.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yes, Eduardo.
Are you auditory?
No?
LES: Maybe not.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Maybe not.
Oh, he's typing.
"Hey guys," he says.
And--
more typing is happening.
LES: Ah, OK.
CHRISTIAN: No question.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Oh,
OK, well then.
LEON: Can I jump in again?
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Sorry?
LES: Sure.
LEON: Just one question, so
are there any new APIs or
things that developers need to
know about as part of this
version three rollout?
LES: Yes.
We're going to be really
slow at releasing them.
But there are some new API is
for dealing with media.
Part of v3 included the
ability to play MPEG-.
That was written entirely
in the new APIs.
Also includes PlayReady
and Smooth Streaming.
And so--
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Closed
captioning, QoS--
LES: Yeah.
So all those will
be coming out.
If you need something in that
list, specifically, you're
welcome to write one of us at
the group at Google, or at our
email addresses.
LesV @ Google, Crispy @
Google, CGK @ Google.
And we'll get you some
information.
But otherwise, we'll probably
publish something, my guess
is, it'll be the beginning
of the new year.
But if you need something
now, let us now.
LEON: OK, thanks.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You're
sighing, Christian,
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, well.
LES: I gave his email address
out publicly.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah,
no that's fine.
I mean, I always like
more email.
LES: [LAUGH]
CHRISTIAN: Just joking.
No, I think some of the APIs
are interesting for
developers.
But the challenge is, for
example, with PlayReady--
effectively, it's the standard
Android DRM framework APIs.
The feature of Android DRM
framework is, it's so generic.
You can pass so many
things to it.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: It's a
framework of frameworks for
frameworks.
CHRISTIAN: Yes, so, especially
with PlayReady DRM, there is
also a lot of different
configurations for
servers and so on.
So you need to be effectively
a PlayReady licensee to have
access to all of the information
that you actually
need to use the framework
successfully.
So if you are a PlayReady
licensee, and you have all the
information, we can help you
plug it into the DRM framework
and make it work.
LES: Yeah, if you weren't
a licensee, you probably
wouldn't have PlayReady
content.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: I think one of
the more interesting wider
APIs, though, is still the
quality of service, and being
able to track your video and
media playback capabilities,
and what have you.
And like one of my other
favorite APIs, which--
I don't know, it's no
v3-specific, the USB host?
CHRISTIAN: No, it's not.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: No, OK.
I just really like that API.
So--
LES: We've have a lot of people
join, though we're
trying to wind up.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: We always tend
to get the most people
joining right when we're
wrapping it up.
But let's see, so Eduardo, you
don't have a question.
And Marcello, do you, by chance,
have a question?
I mean, we're literally just
about to wrap this up here.
OK, Eduardo has one.
He's typing.
LES: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTIAN: Building
up the suspense.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Daniel,
was that you speaking?
DANIEL: That's me.
I'm on a Zoom tablet.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: You're
on a Zoom tablet.
DANIEL: Yes.
So good that you can hear me.
[INAUDIBLE]
KRISTAN UCCELLO:
You know what?
It's too choppy.
I really can't make out
what you're saying.
If you type it in the chat,
we can go from there.
So I'm going to answer Eduardo's
question here. "I
would like to know about the
emulator for Windows if you
guys have any news." Ahh!
My frustration is not
at you, Eduardo.
LES: I'll answer instead.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: All right,
Les, why don't you do that
before I blow a casket.
LES: OK, so we have been within
days of releasing the
emulator for Windows and Mac
for about a month, which is
why Crispy is somewhat
frustrated.
We're waiting for one
bug to get fixed.
As soon as it's fixed,
it'll get released.
It will be the final release
in the 2x series since it
doesn't make sense to release it
for v3, which is basically
all media features, which
wouldn't work on an emulator.
So it's coming.
We apologize.
We understand the importance
of getting this out.
And we are close, is
all I can say.
And Crispy vents his
frustrations regularly in the
internal emails, so there's
no need for him to do it
externally.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yes, yes,
you're probably right.
I've actually had to write a few
apology emails to people
because I get so--
I don't now, I just.
CHRISTIAN: Passionate
about things.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: I'm
very passionate.
And it's like, ahh.
It's--
I'm a very expressive person.
LES: Coming soon.
I'm reminded of the movie
"Buckaroo Banzai," where one
of the main characters
is asked, when are we
going to Planet 10.
And his response is, "real
soon." Or, "soon." And they
ask, "how soon?" And he says
"real soon." So I stepped on
my own punchline, OK.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: All right, so
Eduardo, you said you had one
other question about
picture in picture?
LES: Eduardo's got the
good questions today.
All right, go ahead.
Get I will remain calm.
I will drink.
Christian can answer.
CHRISTIAN: I need to drink more
heavily, too, before those.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: No, I don't--
I kid, of course.
Let's hear your question?
LES: "If maybe, no."
KRISTAN UCCELLO: So yeah,
picture in picture--
it's not going to be--
there's no plan.
There's no road map.
There's nothing to announce of
any capabilities where a
developer's going to be able to
use picture in picture in
the way that, I think, everybody
wants to use it.
The why of it, it's
clouded and murky.
And I'm not going to rehash.
But yeah, the quick answer,
as Les said, is
kind of, no, sorry.
LES: No.
I mean, I can answer
the why, actually.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Oh, OK.
LES: Even though Leon
has open sourced a
picture in picture thing.
Basically--
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Thanks, Leon.
LES: The road map for Google TV
devices is, how can we make
them less expensive.
I mean, that's the fundamental
question.
That doesn't mean there
won't be really
high-end Google TV devices.
There will be.
But we want to make the minimum
Google TV devices as
inexpensive as possible.
So some of the hardware
capabilities that would be
needed to bring picture in
picture to developers might
not be on some devices.
And so, it's kind of just
the way it goes.
That said, shit, take a look
at what Leon just posted in
the chat links.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah, I've
got to take a look and see
what can be done there.
All right, so I think we've had
a pretty good Hangout this
time around.
So we've gone on for
about 45 minutes.
I'm going to wrap it up here,
mainly because Christian and I
have a lot of work we have
to do on our slides.
And time is quickly
running out.
And we have other interruptions
constantly.
So thank you all
for joining us.
I hope everyone's enjoying,
sort of, the way we're
organically formatting
the show.
I guess, if you could
call it a show.
We have news, demos, and then
open discussion questions.
CHRISTIAN: On our weekly
comedy show.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Is
turning into that.
I think we're going to have to
get suits from the '70s next
time and have a big
game show board.
Maybe we'll get someone who
can point at things.
LES: No, we can just back to the
Mexican wrestling masks.
KRISTAN UCCELLO: Yeah, I should
bring those back in.
Actually, I considered
wearing my sombrero.
So I bought a sombrero last
time I was in Mexico.
I haven't brought it in to
wear it yet, but it was
raining this morning.
And I didn't want
to get it wet.
Now it's sunny, ironically.
But maybe-- ah, we'll see what
the New Year brings.
So just to recap, there will be
one more Hangout this year.
We're going to do that
in two weeks time.
And that will be the last
one for the year.
And then we'll pick it back up
in the new year, possibly,
with a weekly approach.
But I think the biweekly
is working out well.
So I think we're to probably
stay with that put for a bit.
But send us your feedback
if you have any.
Thank you all again for joining
us, and keep on
developing.
Ciao.
LES: Aloha.